welcome to the car cast everyone you've
probably noticed that the word
judgmental is used quite a bit these
days there are people who can't seem to
walk out of their house in the morning
without finding judgment all around them
everywhere they go they're telling
people stop judging your judging you're
being judgmental stop judging judgmental
judgmental and the term self-righteous
and holier-than-thou are also quite
popular or generally are used
interchangeably with judgemental and
judging and self-righteous
holier-than-thou you know now it is
possible to be judgmental and
self-righteous and it is bad to be those
things but the problem is that a lot of
people seem to find that judgement and
self-righteousness everywhere they turn
and they paint a picture of American
society as this place that's filled with
puritanical straight-laced prudes who
are holding everyone else to this really
high moral standard as if that's the
great problem in our society right is it
is the high moral standard that we're
all paying hell - of course the truth is
exactly the opposite of that there's
there's basically no moral standard the
moral standard for most people is they
you know whatever people like to do is
good if people like to do it then it's
good and it's right and it's okay that's
the moral standard that most people
operate by but you say that that's wrong
but wait these people like doing it so
it must be okay what are you talking
about how could it be wrong if people
enjoy doing it so no I you know I
wouldn't I don't think that moral
standards is is that unrealistic moral
expectations are our problem
but let's let's let's start with what
does it actually mean to be to be truly
judgmental and self-righteous what does
that mean
well a truly judgmental and
self-righteous person is somebody
without humility who doesn't see their
own flaws and their own weaknesses and
who will tend to put themselves forward
as an example of moral perfection
that's what a judgmental self-righteous
person will do
judge unfairly they judge wrongly they
judge with the wrong heart and they they
consider themselves to be
the paragon of moral virtue and
perfection now in other words a
judgmental self-righteous person that's
someone who feels superior to other
people and and we all have we all do
have a little bit or maybe a lot of that
in us we have some element of that in us
we all struggle with that to a certain
degree
that's called pride that's part of pride
and pride is the is the starting point
of all sin and we all have pride in us
so we all have to some degree or another
we all have these kinds of feelings of
superiority sometimes but I think for
most people their feelings of
superiority are more implicit than
explicit in other words most people
aren't you know I think most people
don't actually literally think to
themselves oh I'm better than other
people I don't think most people think
that exactly it's more like an implicit
sub-conscience subconscious assumption
that they make
and they really have to examine their
own conscience that's what we have to do
we have to do an examination of
conscience to find that within ourselves
and then purge it and repent of it
but I mean I could be wrong I just don't
think the average person when they're
walking by another person on the
sidewalk or they're standing in the
supermarket checkout line with someone
the average person isn't going to look
at someone else and think I am better
than that person
they may sort of think that but it's
buried deep within themselves I think
here's an example of a more explicit
self-righteousness and and in you know a
more explicit example of being
judgmental that you'll find in your
everyday life gossip
you know gossip is a self-righteous
judgmental thing most of the time
because the whole point of gossip what
makes a gossip is that you're all
sitting around talking about these
negative things about someone else who's
not part of the conversation and you're
taking some sick pleasure in discussing
the negative aspects of another person's
life or personality
and what is why do you find pleasure and
you find pleasure in it because it makes
you feel better
really gossipy people people that are
really gossipy the reason they're
gossiping all the time is because it
makes that it keeps inflating their own
ego and their own sense of self-worth
that they find in dwelling and
delighting in other people's flaws
but
I think most of the time that's not
really what's meant when people say
self-righteous and judgmental
they're not talking about gossiping
usually in common usage when someone
accuses you of being judgmental what
they really mean nine times into ten
what they really mean is you have made
me feel uncomfortable about myself
because of a certain moral stand you
have taken or a criticism you have
offered
nine times out of ten that's what they
they're calling you judgmental because
you made them feel uncomfortable
you
and that's why
nowadays it's basically impossible to
have any kind of moral discussion or
debate at all without being called
self-righteous and judgmental because
it's going to make people feel
uncomfortable it's gonna make people
look at themselves
so anytime you say this is right that is
wrong anytime you do that
mine's a lot of people you're
automatically being judgmental
self-righteous because everyone who does
the wrong thing is now going to feel bad
about themselves and because they feel
bad about themselves you're being
judgmental and the only way to not be
judgmental to not be self-righteous is
to never make anyone feel bad about
their life choices I have certainly
found anecdotally
that this comes up quite a bit it won't
surprise you to learn that I get these
accusations a lot and I'm sure that
there have been plenty of times when I
have been self-righteous and judgemental
I'm sure I have been guilty of that
but I also know that
it doesn't really matter how I frame it
if we're talking about speaking
specifically about my writing for a
minute if I'm writing something
where I'm distinguishing right from
wrong
that's wrong we should do that
if I call anything immoral whatsoever
I will be accused of being judgmental
and self-righteous no matter how I say
it
no matter how I frame it and I know
people say well it's because of how you
it's not what you say it's how you say
no actually no that's not what it is
doesn't matter how I say it really
honestly doesn't I could I could be
talking about something and saying oh
this is wrong over here and I could use
myself as an example of the wrong thing
and I tried to be very careful about
that
if I'm talking about a wrong thing a
wrong action if I'm going to use any
specific person by name as an example of
the wrong activity
when applicable I tried to use myself so
one example is I talk a lot about our
obsession with TV and Internet and you
know all these things and we live our
lives revolved around the screens and
that's wrong we should live that way
but anytime I'm talking about that
I always make sure to say I struggle
with this myself I have struggle with
this I still struggle with it it's a
struggle for me now use myself as an
example and I try to communicate that
like this is one of the reasons why you
know this is how I I know what what
effect this has on people's lives
I've been through it I have experienced
but what I found is it doesn't matter
you could use yourself as an example
you could make it you could make it
explicitly clear that you don't think
you're better than anyone
this is this isn't you're not trying to
put you're not superior you know that
you're not
nerd down in the mud with everyone else
struggling and sitting and trying to you
know scrape your way through you could
make that as clear as possible it
doesn't matter you'll still be called
judgmental because if anyone if they get
the scent of if they pick up on the
scent of judgment any kind of judgment
even self judgment they will call you
judgment I mean I have written things
I've written articles where
the entire thing is about my own flaws I
wrote an article for instance but
literally the title of it was I am Judas
okay and the entire article was about my
own sin
you wanna know something I was called
judgmental and self-righteous for that
so it's their art thing sometimes we
just kind of to throw up your hands and
say all right oh I don't know I don't
know what I could do now then if that
even that's judgmental well I don't know
but this isn't this isn't just me by the
way of course I'm not I'm you know I
I'm not the only one who's experienced
this but of course so many times I I
can't tell you how many times I've
gotten emails and so it's almost a daily
occurrence it's not multiple times a day
where I get emails from people confiding
in me that they would like to be more
outspoken they would like to make a
moral stand but they're deathly afraid
of being called self-righteous and
judgmental and I understand you know I
get it
you you don't want to be written off as
judgmental and self-righteous and so
people a lot of times we'll just avoid
the conversation what will happen for me
often is our an email from someone and
they'll tell me about some particular
seeing that's happening around them with
their friends or in their families some
wrong thing that's that's happening and
they want to take a stand and say no we
shouldn't be doing this or this should
be happening
what they don't they're afraid to
because they don't want to be written
off as being judgmental
and they realize
that
you know no matter how they say it
they're going to be called judgmental
because if they're offering a criticism
that makes people feel bad about
themselves well then the accusation will
come
of course this is all ridiculous a
person is not automatically judgmental
just because they've discerned right
from wrong
when a guy says this is wrong and this
is right that doesn't mean he's claiming
to be perfect unless he does claim to be
perfect
in which case fine write him off you
know if somebody is if someone's
approaching it that way and they're
saying I'm never wrong and I'm perfect
listen to me if that's how they're
approaching it then yeah they don't
deserve to be listened to but if someone
is simply saying this is wrong this is
right it doesn't mean they're making any
claims about themselves it doesn't even
necessarily mean that they're claiming
to never do the wrong thing it's just
it's just that they're observing a
something there they're saying they're
making a moral observation which they're
perfectly entitled to do and which they
should do
it's like if a person says
a triangle has three sides
it doesn't mean that they're claiming to
be a geometry expert it doesn't mean
that they're claiming that every time
they draw a per triangle it's perfectly
straight and everything no that's that's
not what they're claiming they're not
making any claims about their own
expertise with shapes and triangles
they're just observing something that is
true and if we happen to live in a
society where everybody rejects the
definition of a triangle then it
behooves anyone who recognizes the
actual definition of a triangle to stand
up and say it even if they're normally
really bad at geometry still they should
stand up and say it
now we happen to live in a society where
a lot of people are very confused about
basic questions of morality a lot of
people in fact reject that objective
morality exists
and so those of us who recognize
objective morality
and who understand at least on a basic
level right from wrong we all have a
duty and a responsibility to stand up
and say it no matter if we are if we are
dirty terrible awful sinners ourselves
that's irrelevant
we would be even greater sinners if we
stayed silent
we have to stand up and say it
responsibilities
it is not automatically judgmental or
self-righteous
not everyone who distinguishes between
right and wrong is claiming to be a
saint
it could be that someone who does that
they realize that they're a sinner they
know that they're a sinner they
acknowledge their own sin
and therefore they take sin personally
and they hate it all the more because
they have dealt with it
and felt its effects
now contrary to
it's a popular belief
the bible does not actually forbid
judging
and that's what you'll hear you'll hear
well it's you shouldn't you call
yourself a Christian but you're running
around judging the Bible says don't
judge Bible Bible says it right there
stop judging
yeah you know what the Bible says that
if you are like looking with if you've
got these blinders on where you can only
see two words at a time in the Bible
then yeah you could find the phrase stop
judging and then you could take that
phrase and remove it from its entire
context and say oh the Bible says stop
judging but you see those words appear
in the Bible there you go see
but of course if you're approaching the
Bible that way you could the Bible will
say anything you wanted to say if you're
approaching it like basically like a
word search or something where you can
as long as you find the words or the
letters in the Bible somewhere and you
can arrange them in whatever way and
remove them for their context well in
that case then the Bible can justify
anything you wanted to justify but the
Bible does not actually taken in context
Jesus is not telling us as a blanket
statement not to judge what he's warning
against is judging wrongly see he's
warning against judgments that are made
wrongly and with the wrong heart he's
also he's also warning us that even if
you judge rightly even if you make a
right judgment because in John 7:24
Jesus says don't judge by appearance but
Judge with right judgment so that's a
come it's not even just that Jesus is
saying you can judge he's saying judge
with right judgement he's commanding us
to judge you should judge but do it
rightly with right judgment but he also
tells us
the measure with which you measure will
be measured out to you what he's saying
is if you hold people to a certain
standard even if it's the right stem you
know even if you're doing it correctly
you better hold yourself to the same
step you better hold yourself to a
higher standard than you hold everyone
else
so if you have this very clear moral
sense and you're very intolerant of sin
and wickedness which is a which is a
good way to be that's how we should be
but you better apply it to yourself
and so if you're very hard on other
people
and and and very you know and not
interested in hearing excuses
which again there's not necessarily
anything wrong with being that way you
better be twice as hard on yourself
and you better be dismissing your own
excuses right away
this is also a Jesus get sat in the you
know the verse the other verse that's
tossed around by the don't judge camp is
the verse where Jesus discusses the
speck in our brother's eye and the way
that this is paraphrased and kind of
boiled down most of the time we've
distilled it down to what Jesus is
saying is never worry about your brother
speck because you have a bigger speck or
you know your brother has a speck you
have a log so never worry about the
space that's not what Jesus is saying
let's look at the actual verse he says
why do you look at the speck of sawdust
in your brother's eye and pay no
attention to the plank in your own eye
how can you say to your brother let me
take the speck out of your eye when all
the time there's a plank in your own eye
you hypocrite first take the plank out
of your own eye and then so there's a
two-part process here first step take
the plank out of your own eye second
step and then you will see clearly to
remove the speck from your brother's eye
somehow that last part of the of the
last sentence is is is left out when
people talk about this verse the whole
and then part is completely removed
but we can't remove that
because what Jesus is saying is yeah
absolutely help your brother with his
speck don't just don't just leave him
there to languish with his uh with with
the speck in his eye help them with the
speck but you can't do that until you
worry about the sin in your own life and
if there's a big if there if there if
there is this this big sin or any kind
of sin in your life that you are
refusing to confront then you're gonna
be blinded by that and you won't be able
to help anywhere else
so worry about yourself first and your
own sin judge yourself your own sin
and then you can help other people in
their walk
work out your own salvation with fear
and trembling there better be some fear
and trembling when you look at your own
sin you should hate your own sin you
should detest you should be disgusted by
you will not be able to help anyone else
in their walk and in their faith if you
don't have that attitude about your own
sin
we talk about hate the sin love the
sinner which is I think you know there's
a there's a deep truth to that phrase
but what Jesus is telling us is
you better apply that to yourself you
better hate your own sin too and hate it
most of all because it's a sin that
you're guilty of and you're responsible
for
so
be humble in other words I mean we could
really boil it down to that be home
don't think too highly of yourself know
that you're a sinner that you have
sinned that your sins are disgusting and
terrible and awful and dark and hideous
and and do you know go to war against
your own sin
repent of it
and if you're if you're going to stand
for what is right in the world which you
should you better apply it to yourself
but if you're doing that and if that's
how you really approach things then go
out and speak the truth and stand for
what's right
and you can be confident that you're
doing it righteously not self
righteously because you're not putting
yourself forward as the standard for
righteousness that's what it means to be
self righteous by definition it is to
put yourself forward as the standard for
righteousness but if you're looking to
God as the standard and you're holding
everyone including yourself to that
standard then you're not being self
righteous and you're not being
judgmental
if you're saying to people look at me do
what I am doing that self-righteous but
if you're saying if you're saying to
everyone let's all look up there and
follow him
and I'm in the same camp as you I have
to look up there too let's all look up
there
that's not self-righteous that is not
judgmental
that is correct that is right that is
righteous
and if you approach it that way and
people still refuse to listen
and they still throw around judgmental
and self-righteous and all these words
it's only because they don't want to see
their own imperfections that's the great
irony here is that they accuse you of
thinking you're perfect when really they
are the ones who think they are perfect
they are the self-righteous ones because
they have positioned themselves not God
as the standard of righteousness
they are saying this is right because
it's what I do that is self righteous
that is the ferry that is self righteous
perfectly illustrated and exemplified is
the person who who insists that whatever
they do must be right because they're
doing it that is arrogance that is pride
that is that is that is
self-righteousness that's what that is
it turns out in the end
most of the time the people who go
around accusing everyone else of being
self-righteous they are the
self-righteous ones
because they refuse to even consider
they may be doing the wrong thing they
won't even consider it
that's self-righteousness so we should
pray for them and we should you know
pray pray for their own awakening
and continue to work on ourselves with
fear and trembling
and also continue to stand for what's
right and what's true
and
if we know that we're approaching it the
right way and doing it the right way and
with the right heart
we don't have to worry about the
accusations and the insults when they
come thanks for watching thanks for
listening everybody Godspeed